Es gab Zeiten,
da war sie fast allgegenwärtig:
die Musikkassette.
Heute gehört sie zu den
aussterbenden Tonträgern.
Der Autor und Journalist Jan Drees weiß,
wo immer noch Kassetten verkauft werden.
Zum Beispiel im Plattengeschäft
„Staalplaat“ in Berlin.
Hier gibt es Kassetten
mit Musik aus aller Welt.
Jan Drees lässt in seinem Buch
„Kassettendeck
– Soundtrack einer Generation“
viele Musiker und Künstler
ihre ganz persönlichen
Kassetten-Geschichten erzählen.
Das absolut Faszinierende
an der Kassette war doch,
dass auf einmal Leute ihr eigenes
Programm zusammenstellen konnten.
Das war „Broadcast Yourself“,
wie wir es jetzt von YouTube kennen,
in allererster Form.
Sandra Heinzelmann ist dem Tonträger
aus Plastik bis heute treu geblieben.
Sie legt unter dem Künstlernamen „_SMH“
in Berliner Bars (mit) Kassetten auf.
Ein Kassetten-DJ-Set vorzubereiten,
ist aufwendig:
Vor den Auftritten spult die DJane
jede Kassette an die richtige Stelle,
um nicht vor Ort Zeit beim
Suchen der Songs zu verlieren.
Man muss halt durch die Musik blättern,
so wie früher im CD-Laden
oder Plattenladen,
und nimmt eben das Ding raus,
den Tonträger,
und setzt ihn ein und muss
spulen und damit arbeiten.
Das hat was Haptisches, und das hat …
das macht Spaß!
Die „Große Deutsche Funkausstellung“
in Berlin im Jahre 1963.
Die niederländische Firma Philips stellt
die erste Kassette samt Recorder vor.
Anfangs ist die Klangqualität
zwar noch bescheiden,
doch durch verbesserte Technik
werden auch anspruchsvolle Hörer
schnell zu Kassettenfans.
Das Aufnehmen von sogenannten
„Mixtapes“ mit Lieblingsliedern,
oft für den oder die Angebetete,
entwickelt sich zur
eigenen Wissenschaft
– samt liebevoller Covergestaltung.
1979 bringt die Firma Sony
den Walkman auf den Markt.
Die Kassette bestimmt fortan das
Lebensgefühl einer ganzen Generation.
Dazu steckt in dieser Kassette auch
eine Demokratisierung der Musik.
Gerade im (im) Osten, wo es ja nur
zwei große Label gab, Staatslabel,
da haben Kulturfunktionäre bestimmt,
wer da drauf kann.
Und auf einmal konnten Bands
vorbei an der Staatsräson
ihre Musik aufnehmen und
auch einfach verbreiten.
Abseits der globalen Verkaufsstrategien
der großen Plattenfirmen
betreibt Conrad Rodenberg in Berlin
sein Kassettenlabel „Froggi Records“.
In Kleinstauflagen von 20 bis 100 Stück
wird eigene Musik oder die befreundeter
Bands aus aller Welt vertrieben.
Hier entsteht alles in Handarbeit
– von den Kopien
bis zur Covergestaltung.
Sie verkaufen auch die Kassetten meist
selbst, zum Beispiel bei Konzerten.
Ich mag auch total gern daran, dass es…
ja… dass es einfach hörbar
vergänglich ist das Ganze.
Also dass… dass Abnutzung hörbar ist
und dass das dadurch einfach auch
ein bisschen mehr Persönlichkeit kriegt.
In Deutschland hatte die Musikkassette
ihr Rekordjahr 1991
mit 109 Millionen verkauften Exemplaren.
2014 waren es nur noch rund 200.000.
[Sich an] die Kassette als Medium
mit ihrer Aura zu erinnern,
bedeutet auch, sich [an] ein
Stück Musikgeschichte zu erinnern.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das auch für
jedes Komprimierungsformat gilt,
mit dem wir jetzt
unsere Musik kleinrechnen.
Ganz in Vergessenheit geraten
wird die Kassette wohl erst mal nicht
– zu viele Erinnerungen hängen an ihr.